So the King's Indian has always
scored points, let
's do E4 now and let's
see.
I only know everything from
hearsay, but
the dragon
now looks similar to the
normal variants
I put it somewhere on c3 or something like that,
I don't know how to do it,
somehow I could have played a lot more powerfully,
well, okay, that doesn't seem that fast at first, but still
F3 G4,
well,
I'm making progress now, I have this field or
yes, I think that's calming down for now  My
own king is also relatively secure,
you can't immediately see how black is
supposed to get there
and I still have a few
chances, wow,
but that's weakening a lot or,
for example, Queen G5,
we have five,
for example,
yes, but that's very noticeable  dangerous
from
maybe don't play black and white like
knight the five queen G6 knight F4
then with the idea
so I would like to take it now what's next then I have
no idea
so
now we do six there is something against it
yes no idea
do me eight I also have bishops  C4
again ne then through Toni 6
at least
the next move then simply GH5 or
or bishop the three could also go
depending on what he moves now he has
done that what happens now if I beat F6
Run
also
Queen G6 first so that you six
then  Bishop E6
Queen F3 I now have rook G1 and that
also threatens H6.
Of course madness here in this position
has completely torn everything open. I do
n't think it
was that dangerous before